the grim discovery was made in a remote
area on the outskirts of san antonio in
texas a man working nearby heard a cry
for help and saw a trailer with the
doors partially open
inside there were dozens of bodies piled
on top of one another temperatures in
the area had reached 39 degrees
centigrade on monday those who survived
mostly young adults and children were
too weak to get out of the trailer
patients that we saw were hot to the
touch
they were suffering
from heat stroke heat exhaustion
no signs of water in the vehicle it was
a refrigerated tractor trailer but there
was no visible working ac unit on that
rig
the victims are believed to be migrants
who cross the u.s mexico border looking
for a better life this appears to be one
of the worst cases of migrant deaths in
the u.s in recent years so the plight of
migrants seeking refuge is always a
humanitarian crisis but tonight we are
dealing with a horrific human tragedy
so i would urge you all to think
compassionately and pray for the
deceased
the ailing
the families
the trailer was found near a major
highway that stretches all the way to
the border with mexico san antonio
police have made arrests
we have
three people
in custody
we don't know if they are
absolutely connected to this or not
this investigation has been turned over
to hsi it is now a federal investigation
the migration crisis at the u.s southern
border is a problem for president biden
whose approval ratings are low
republicans are focusing on the issue
ahead of the midterm elections in
november
human rights groups say the crisis is
being politicized by both sides
in the meantime migrants continue to
cross the border in this case with
tragic consequences
victoria gatenbee al jazeera